bonsoir vers l aventure à merci d'être
avec nous en direct depuis les
états-unis hillary clinton qui exhorte
donc joe biden a donné des vaccins anti
qu'ovide aux pays pauvres
elle se plaint hillary clinton que la
russie et la chine soit en tête de la
diplomatie des vaccins dit elle
intéressant qu hillary clinton s'exprime
sur le sujet elle a raison les états
unis sont à la traîne et se concentre
sur la vaccination de leurs propres
populations
ils n'aident pas à la vaccination du
reste du monde mais dans le même temps
c'est assez attristant de voir des
politiques au pouvoir ou non discuté de
la vaccination dire qu'il pourrait
s'agir d'une compétition d'un
concurrence au niveau international que
certains pays s'en tire mieux ou moins
bien que c'est une mauvaise chose que
les états unis devraient être au centre
des efforts de vaccination
il s'agit en fait d'un effort
communautaire mondial et tous les pays
devraient s'allier pour essayer de
vacciner et d'éradiquer ce virus aussi
rapidement que possible
il ne devrait pas y avoir de concurrence
il devrait y avoir un effort commun pour
vacciner le plus rapidement possible
alors il faudrait tout de même que la
russie fournit 56 pays dont certains en
amérique du sud ce qui ne plaît pas
nécessairement washington c'est triste
car je comprends en fin de compte
l'administration byden nous sommes en
honneur en matière de co vide dans le
monde nous devons nous occuper d'eux
nous d'abord mais c'est tragique si l'on
étudie les chiffres il agence france
presse a avait analysé et découvert que
56% des vaccins contre lacko vides ont
été distraits dans des pays qui
représentent 16% de la population et un
chiffre très bas a été dispensée dans
les pays les plus pauvres
donc que ce soit la russie la chine
l'allemagne la france ou dans les autres
pays ils doivent s'occuper de leur
population mais doivent également
proposé d'aider à vacciner le reste de
l'humanité
c'est une bonne chose et cela ne doit
pas être considérée comme une course on
ne devrait pas se dire les etats unis
sont en retard si la russie va plus
c'est un scandale
mais ce n'est pas une course ce n'est
pas une compétition
l'objectif c'est de vacciner autant que
possible et pour moi tous les
producteurs de vaccins
tous les scientifiques devraient
partager leurs brevets avec le reste du
monde afin que toutes les organisations
tous les pays puissent produire ces
vaccins qui sont si nécessaire pour à la
population dans le monde entier afin que
nous puissions tourner la page sur cette
pandémie et nous employer à construire
un meilleur avenir
alors il faut dire que ça c'est dans un
monde libéral
idéal telle aventure parce que pour le
moment l'europe part évidemment
également est pire que les états unis
l'amérique est dans une situation
compliquée elle aussi sur le plan de la
vaccination et la crise sanitaire en
général oui tout à fait l'administration
baden se débrouille lieu que
l'administration 30 mai il y a toujours
beaucoup d'écueils de grands pans de la
population américaine ne souhaite pas se
faire vacciner car ils redoutent le fait
qu'il vienne du gouvernement américain
évoque l'idée qui pourrait y avoir une
nouvelle vague dans les mois à venir car
les gens ne respectent toujours pas les
consignes sanitaires
certaines personnes demandent de laisser
tomber les masques alors d'autre que
d'autres affirment que c'est nécessaire
donc pour moi ce problème va persister
aux états unis pendant encore de
nombreux mois
certaines personnes espère qu'on puisse
arriver à bout de cette pandémie
mais nous avons encore beaucoup de mois
à venir car nous sommes un pays très
politisée et l'autre coronavirus est un
sujet très politisée alors que c'est en
fait un problème sanitaire
merci beaucoup à la ventura présentateur
rt américain d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de washington ce soir